hello and welcome to this video
Grandmaster jaws with that no name but
pretty high rating well nowadays India
has so many strong GMS you can cannot
really tell what that is okay have some
kind of ratty system you so very solid
set up yeah you can actually say for
both sides okay maybe flick h3n and and
then yeah I probably have to go in for
him
yeah sorry for the background noises I
have something going on in the kitchen
and I don't think I could have didn't
find a way to completely get the sound
out of the recording yeah I'm trying to
play before in this position and I hope
that I can get this in before here takes
takes bishop tea eggs would be one hmm
it's not it's not that great between be
two boots maybe 95 hmm
9h for night f5 is also an idea who I
don't know i don't like this position so
much couldn't be two nights if five is
really annoying and i don't really see a
movie i'll be one looks wrong I mean
blunder say three mostly that doesn't
also help we should see five as possibly
coming don't like my position but it's
suppose canned of normal line something
probably I played wrong them okay I have
to play some kind of move not happy with
it but
so I can do a G for now but I'd weakens
my some squares quite a bit but so ok I
think I have to make some kind of
commitment him some night will come to
f4 i guess but I'm happy store that I
have this in and this isn't so bad
interesting whoa okay hmm
so my queen my king side is slightly
weakened the big thing i said this night
is like ultimately in ultimate annoyance
dream two f-4s it's not really a thing
wow there's some way to get rid of the
night
I'm taking ages absolutely taking ages
now is completely killing me here also
very well played or barely played on my
end probably probably both
check
9f three maybe just it's a it's really
awful maybe maybe maybe I can hang on a
little bit of Bishop c5 mmm he's got
Bishop c5 okay Queen f6 there are some
slight chances with bishops III if he's
not careful Oh McQueen was just hanging
time morning whoo okay thank you resins
that was pretty awful yeah I mean maybe
I don't know let's see that was a very I
was very tricky and he played with
various very quickly it's funny I see
that the computer likes my position
actually around him it just wants to
take with the jeep on yeah II for reform
was very strong yeah you kind of almost
automatically take with the EPO one
because you kind of think this Bishop
should have some scope but this is
stronger because now this is not a
stable peace the computer line is quite
quite funny it wants to play this and
take him after which I'm definitely okay
now so that is a real problem I
shouldn't take with this and now the
engine wants to take f6 and I didn't
consider that at all
that looks pretty terrible strategic
game giving him the dark squares but
maybe maybe I should
hmm yeah I mean after that it got really
awful and it's funny yet it's not check
doesn't seem to lose straight away but
it is pretty bad I'm Bishop g5 now yeah
this doesn't work because he assured c5
was I was thinking here but he can take
check joe hooks are strong and that also
was probably winning i had simply
blended the Queen was bit I was
completely shaken okay this game went
but I really shouldn't play this opening
I think this is a line that I had looked
at a very long time ago and I really
didn't like the position here her white
I think black has a very comfortable
position here no bad pieces good to
control over those squares and it's
difficult for what you get before in
ultimately so not not a great position
out of the opening hymn wow thanks for
watching